bon jusqu'au 31 décembre claude lelouch
a transformé sa salle de projection qui
est en haut de l'avenue junot est tout
près du moulin de la galette comme
chantait fréhel et en salle de concert
pour vous ouais et vous allez chanter
alors qu'il chantait cadeau merveilleux
qui m'a fait et vous chantez beaucoup
beaucoup de ferrer mais pas seulement
vous étudiez ont chanté deux spectacles
en principe ne peut plus en faire qu'un
parce qu'il faut que ça s'arrête à 10h30
11h à cause des voisins non je disais ça
que je les vois ils ont le droit de
dormir mais donc sur trente chansons
l'enchantent plus que 15 et ça fait un
spectacle et demi donc il ya un mélange
de chansons de léo ferré ou une chanson
louis aragon bien mis en musique par léo
ferré et puis des chansons de philippe
sharman mois et en janvier il ya un
album qui sort les auchan de féret ça
c'est philippe l'otage enlevé les
honneurs mais aussi mon frère moi c'est
monsieur le tas c est pourquoi ferrer
parce que vous avez fait un album sur de
nouveaux chantiers brassage y entend une
chanson pour l'album de joël favreau sur
brassens mais je verrai si je débute
doucement ma vie une fois quand j'avais
20 ans et puis on faisait de l'est sur
elle connaître on était des copains
place de la sorbonne on applaudit fort
quand on l'a dépassée
il est venu boire un coup avec nous et
ai vus a pas dit un mot et puis j'ai vu
une deuxième fois il ya quatre ans quand
le jeu château de cène
trop bataclan et lui jouaient au déjazet
je vais demander une
une voix off et avec beaucoup d'humilité
il a accepté de le faire et là j'ai
entendu bien entendu dire cette phrase
j'aimerais bien que mes chansons ça
chantait par quelqu'un d'autre et on a
commencé à faire ce disque l'âme mais
nous à une vitesse il est capoté avant
et le disque sort après sa mort ce qui
est un peu dommage mais ça devait être
un cadeau qu'on lui fasse avant et
qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi comme
chanson parce que c'est énorme le
répertoire différent on a envie de tout
chanter tout santé est bien celle ci
donc bon il ya une bonne part des
chansons qui sont des textes de louis
aragon et puis à piano du pot
les chansons de jean roger caussimon je
sais pas vous dire la terre que le soir
au spectacle un vieux vélo donc c'est
pas toujours les mêmes quoi parce qu'on
a un répertoire un peu qui déborde un
petit peu c'est vrai moi qui demande un
petit peu du la durée du spectacle et
pour vous il n'ya pas de différence
entre le léo ferré qui auteur de ces
textes et le nouveau ferry qui a mis en
musique
aragon baudelaire verlaine au moins
paulina vraiment musiciens non je pense
pas que philippe chavent elle est vitale
dans cette histoire parce que c'était un
grand musicien n'est ce pas lié au fait
que je ne fus pas alors ça peut prêter
ma voix à quelqu'un mais il fallait
l'accompagnement de quelqu'un qui sache
a arrangé à nouveau ter fallait trouver
un moyen pour que ce soit plus
intéressant nous entendre nous que léo
ferré qui chante elle est même très bien
ses chansons avec avait besoin de
personne il fallait trouver une
personnalité sur le plan des
arrangements de l'orchestration des
harmonies tout ça qu'ils soient pas
n'importe qui votre carrière de
musicienne a commencé sur scène aux
francofolies de la rochelle mât de 12
ans de carrière
de quoi là où on mon aventure votre
aventure le chanteur elle a commencé aux
francofolies de la rochelle en 86
oui c'est ça ouais et apporter bectu en
cours qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui vous
avait poussé à faire ça et bah c'est à
dire que j'avais fait une fille une
jeune femme qui m'a demandé peut-être
pas tant et puis je voulais vous avez
fait une chanson pour vous rattraper
peuvent et non c'est je suis libre cet
enfant vivra plus longtemps avec mon
image qui avec moi même et je voulais
qu'elle est l'image d'un jeune rocker
plutôt que d'un vieux professeur de
philosophie débat clos comme gens les
plus produits pour maintenant elle va
vivre avec le souvenir de son papa quoi
il faudrait que ce souvenir soit et la
chanson sale [ __ ] une place importante
pour vous
à dire que dans votre univers quotidien
vous chantez beaucoup vous écouter vous
savez à partir d'un certain âge les les
contemporains soir et c'est un point
derrière comme son nom l'indiqué la
somme heureux mais c'est bonjour et donc
comme disait guy bedos et le camembert
qui durera non c'est à dire que s'est
conjuguée avec le fait que je suis très
ami avec philippe carmin et que donc
comme depuis la mort de serge et à deux
ans bientôt 3 et contemporains sont
rares c'est lié à ça que c'est à dire
que je n'ai plus de raison objective de
chanter je suis acteur de cinéma au
théâtre c'est mon métier ça a été mon
aventure maintenant c'est mon métier et
mon aventure c'est de chanter et
l'écriture entre la chanson et les
arcades à sa carte que vous mais vous
trouvez vous sortiez puisque là il y
avait déjà fait sa maison à moi que ça
c'est vrai pourquoi pas un jour sans une
ligne j'étais accusé d' accusé de
corrompre la jeunesse française
c'est une citation de horace pourtant
oui mais comme j'ai inventé c'était mal
vu personne ne craint personne a trouvé
de trace de sidaction d'orages dans
horace nous l'a dit est chez les
linéaires c'est moi qui les ai inventées
nous l'a dit et si les lignes à parce
que le moulinet en latin saint brieuc
sans une ligne sans une phrase une ligne
d'avants alors les douanes sont parés du
livre ont attrapé à la gare du nord est
montré dans les tribunaux et puis j'ai
été condamné à un mois de prison
ça vous fait rire trouver oui
nyamwasa faire c'est comme un mode usine
ses expériences quand j'ai toute la vue
s'échangent mais que buzhala billancourt
toute sa vie je comprends qu'il rêve
d'autre chose
mais simone de beauvoir pas la ministre
mais quelle que soit la condition
ouvrière après simone veil ah ouais
ouais
de boer moi j'aurais pu voir que je suis
ou quelqu'un d'autre
voilà je me suis planté c'est pas moi
qui me les groupes ça repousse des
amygdales
ou alors est ce que c'est que je devais
simone veil dont qui arrive quand ils
sont ouverts hier à les négliger le fait
que la condition ouvrière network peut
compter les obligatoires passé un mois
j'ai pas grave je produis simone
dramédie on ne naît pas femme on le
devient raide comprendre puisque j'avais
déjà passé neuf mois de prison en
espagne pour avoir tué un garde s'il est
un mois à paris c'était plutôt peinard
en plus il me faisait un sursis donc je
suis toujours libres parmi vous je suis
très heureux d'être parmi nous d'accord
vous avez chanté aragon tout à l'heure
dont je sais que par ailleurs vous vous
savez oui c'est même pas quelqu'un de ta
c'est pourtant dans ce livre là vous
liront dommage pour mon genou
oui mesure rend pas hommage pour fond
rouge vous aimez bien le rouge au front
rows elle s'appelle maglio gosse 1992
célia disons type r ça fait croire aux
gens si vous lisiez bien le poème fond
rouge le petit cheval y qu'on commence à
comprendre il dit et maintenant j'ai les
front rows s'est amenée par ce ver qui
l'a fait mettre en plus en prison vous
les avons j'ai aussi descendre les
frites camarades et la sauce la même
part de sonder les traîtres camarades
cette fois ci serait mieux et la honte
front rouge donc
d'après ses allures alors comment vous
comprenez que cet homme là pas une
chanson un poème aussi superbe que vous
avez chanté je peux atteindre wet un
très grand poète
bon ben ça se paye ça se paye quelque
part moi j'ai pas un emploi j'étais un
mec super nous sommes heureux dit il
mais je prends un grand poète bon mais
louis aragon il lisait 4 il parlera il
écrivait tout le temps a finalement
evian dire autant presque de léo ferré
al'inverse le faire il ya un mec super
je réponds pas que c'est un grand poète
à chaque fois qu'est ce que je vais dire
il ya des chansons que j'ai écarté parce
que j'ai trouvé un petit peu banal mais
quand tu peux lire comme la deuxième
année jusqu'au bout ça qu'ils ont très
très belle apparemment mme équipe
ouais enfin j'écrirai mieux que ça si je
savais à parler du même sujet